mmm there's something like sensual about
just sucking the chicken off the bone
welcome to night-in night-out
the show will reek impair a home-cooked
tasty recipe to a night out at a fancy
restaurant today we're going on not one
but two dates and then at the end we're
each going to pick which one was the
better date today's food is roast
chicken you're pretty
I'm sure like this professional chef is
going to make a very good roast chicken
but I'm sure absolutely better than mine
it's gonna be a roast chicken with
Brussels sprouts and red russet mashed
potatoes apparently it's Brussels
sprouts I always thought it was Brussels
sprouts we can get a young chicken a
fresh young chicken or a free-range
young chicken what do you think Ariel
young chicken fresh them chicken
free-range young sitting got a tiny
little fresh jump chick roast chicken is
the most special simple meal yeah and
then there's the waiting for it to cook
part that's like the date half the fun
it's like the date in itself
we made it B is here too well let's get
the cookie
you get like little pieces of paper
towels stuck inside at the chicken
mustard yeah of course it's stuck you
goofball I'm making my chicken butter
spread chicken better it's butter salt
pepper and sage there we go we got our
chicken slathered in butter and sage
yeah me rub it inside the skin I don't
have any string on me like a pin string
get rid of it we're putting Garrett's be
met the bird in the cavity you can see
me but that sounds like a terrible idea
yeah yep yep okay put the Bourbon so
whatever are we going to do for an hour
get in there oh my your carton has been
played and won by well you want some
arrows working on the brussels meanwhile
i am doing the mashed potatoes you put
them in the water and then you boil them
for a little while i do this thing
called the fork test
oh if the fork goes in and out pretty
cleanly huh then they're ready all right
let's get the garlic in there throw the
potatoes in we have this nice
distribution of labour where I do the
meats
that's Jamshid oh so veggies I like to
massage my vegetables
he likes massages meat like that these
have so much oil on them they're gonna
get super crusty to do the e key so we
have to we have to drink it fast Cheers
[Music]
yeah my legs a little splayed out this
chairs like what do you get from the
bottom I don't know I read on the
internet one way hmm is Thanksgiving you
know anything I kind of do all three
okay ready all right oh no I'm so sorry
that's that's really good that's really
good as potatoes are perfect
yeah they are so we're the Brussels nice
like garlic yeah Brussels are great hmm
Saigon is good its moist tender so
crispy on the outside
why do bars charge like $14 for Brussels
sprouts when you can get them at the
grocery store yeah yeah all right let's
talk about these meditators the berries
like a big chicken with garlic do you
have to be so good you're right you get
a kick in the buns there we go
so that was date number one that was our
night in it's time for the night out but
first we gotta change we're going to
Middle East it is a fancy French
restaurant on the west side of La it's
gonna take us about 45 minutes to get I
would rather not be arriving in the
daytime because it is so I'm so sorry I
didn't fix your air conditioning I think
I think that's bothering me the most now
though is that the backs of my knees are
sweating that's the worst like the
nastiest sweat why should we pay $60 for
something we can they go right why
should we pay out it's not it's six
thousand Wow time's running out what is
it that you like about rich chicken do
you like the crispy skin crispy skin
crispy skin and then it's gonna be moist
sometimes chicken breasts can dry out
moist breasts
Morris breasts did somebody say moist
breasts actually my breasts are very
moist right now I'm Josiah Citrin I'm
the chef and owner of Malisse restaurant
hello California so today we're gonna do
one of our classic dishes it's roasted
chicken black truffle stuff underneath
the skin and today we'll be serving it
with white asparagus and morel mushrooms
here we have our white asparagus is it
yellow wine asparagus juice little cream
and here we have our morel mushrooms to
get a nice flavor we have mashed
potatoes here do you have any tips for
someone that's trying to cook a chicken
at home it's really great when you brine
it so I brine it and the air drying over
that I'll frigerator mmm it's great
because it makes the skin much crispier
and delicious
it could be in the oven like one hour
take it out then it's it me and it
continues to cook so we serve you the
breast first and then we do a second
service of the leg cause you really
can't cook a chicken breast and leg
perfectly at the same time that's where
we run what no but we do too but at the
end we take it off after the table we
set it back in the kitchen wow they were
a bit sear in a pan at the end was the
butter I know you like butter I do like
butter hit you out with the butter
comparing the home to the fancy
restaurant yes I totally messed up
carving the chicken earlier there what's
the best way to carve a chicken I'm
going to show you oh my gosh troit look
at this it's a real baller move to order
the tableside yeah take the legs off
first but you know we're gonna send it
back gonna cook a little more oh my god
straight down the mill here we have our
beautiful teacher for you
[Music]
shuffle in there brother
well mushrooms is a decadent dish I
never knew chicken could be so decadent
[Music]
I'm blow it did you imagine being in a
crowded restaurant where everyone's like
oh the sauce looks so good are you ready
[Music]
you just started mmm this is Jay this is
chicken 2.0 apparently I've been over
cooking chicken my entire life mashed
potatoes mashed potatoes in our dish but
they weren't this there's a flavor that
I don't bring you guys might be the
truffle sauce
I gotta up my sauce game yeah joe sauce
is worth yeah truffle is just like make
my mouth salivate put it on everything
hot dog boom chuckles aha hamburgers
truffle sauce cereal truffle sauce so
here we of course - it's a chicken suit
the barley black barley and white
asparagus wait that was a complete
surprise chickens I did not know chicken
soup is coming sounds like the most
comforting chicken soup I've ever had
that profitable it's like dessert but
with a chicken and this is even more
deliciously succulent it's actually
magical
[Music]
maybe date night amazing I feel awesome
the big question is did we like the
night in or the night out better I mean
we had 90 minutes to just hang out yeah
but the presentation at movies cuts it
puts it on your plate
serves ready to go yeah so it was so
romantic
you feel so special so your winner is
again I just love well what about you
whose thing I talked pretty big game
about my chicken put the chicken that
Malisse is not something that could have
made that was a level of roast chicken I
didn't think existed well that's true
where do you get I don't even know what
to do with them I would use that we're a
dog we're like a bloodhound bloodhound
know what hounds get truffle no pigs
pigs that's what it is my answer
I gotta also go for the night out yes
well thanks for watching let us know
whether you thought the night in or the
night out was better and comment below
what we should do knit that was good
oh that was the dogs trigger yeah
there's on the floor I put on here plate
oh I didn't think you're gonna eat it
how's your back of a nice wet I don't
know well yeah that's what a good meal
can do oh oh yes